hello lovely people it is time
for the trailer of marvel studios's thor
love and thunder a movie that i feel
like a lot of people are very hotly
anticipating
in large part because well for me it's
been for me personally
taika waititi um very big fan of
my
sort of fellow neighbor countrymen new
zealander i'm australian a lot of
respect but also i just love the
majority of what he's made plus i
imagine it's gonna be a pretty great
time i'm a very big fan of norse
mythology and uh happened to know quite
a bit about it not that it'll be
anything accurate to that but i still
like seeing the easter eggs uh these
days anyway so let's jump in let's watch
it this is on the marvel entertainment
channel and it already has 1.2
million views
in one hour
wild
[Music]
kids get to pop corner let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odenson
he was no ordinary man
he was a god
after saving planet earth for the 500th
time thor set off on a new journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead
he reclaimed his title
as the one and only thor
oh spook too soon
jane
the old ex-girlfriend
what's a family three four years eight
years seven months and six days give or
take
my own beautiful
[Music]
you're right
the change he's gone through
about
is themselves
so this is my vow
all gods will die
christian bale i did not know about that
costume
i just want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back there
they may have already announced that i
did not know
he's just my first bad guy
[Music]
you never forget your first
but you
are not like the other gods that kill
[Music]
because i have something worth fighting
for
that is him right
damn
[Music]
wow
let's see who you are and take off your
disguise
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
[Laughter]
eventually great
wow that looks like
so totally different to a lot of the
other mama movies and it's so wild the
changes that thor as a character has
been through for the mcu um i mean like
canonically to north smith he is
supposed to be a really bad guy he's not
a hero at all he's a belligerent drunk
murderer like genocidal murderer
this is telling him to start being a
little bit more of an [ __ ] a little
bit more belligerent a little bit more
burpee um but obviously marvel's never
gonna go too far down that road and it
doesn't matter it's still a fun take
this is a cool trailer it's fun it's
visually interesting definitely sets the
tone um looks like they are leaning
hotter into the huma i love the settings
i love the way asgard looks
and uh
the lady thor
has been in marvel comics before if you
weren't aware that's not a thing that's
new to um
[Music]
this movie at all and there's just one
thing i think she's a great actress and
i'm sure it's gonna be really fun
there's just one thing that drives me
nuts about it if i can find a good shot
of her is the way that her armor fits
what is this
okay i'm covering it hang on
we just
what is this
boobs
it's such a weird thing to care about
but i do care
boobs do not sit in line with your
shoulders
if this is supposed to be some kind of
chest armor to imply that she has
titties
why is her chest even higher than his
pecs that's a peck right
still under the armpit
hers is like the it's like this dent
that's in line with this shoulder like
sure it's probably in line with the
armpit
boobs would actually go probably like
this
right like they hang onto your pec
where your armpit is they should be down
even if you're wearing something that's
push-up what they should be down here
it just i just find it so distracting
it's it's annoying to look at
i'm sure most people won't care about
that but i certainly do um very fun
trailer they're very good at making
trailers always excited to find out what
in the trailer isn't actually in the
movie um let me get an idea of
ow villain who again i did i was so
surprised by christian bale i don't know
if that has been um
announced before it's entirely possible
that it has been
type person doesn't really care about
cameos storyline is number one and yeah
that's fair yeah
i'm honestly interested in what they'll
be doing with gore the god butcher
mainly because the fact that he got as
powerful from the comics and the
symbiote haven't been introduced in the
mb mcu yet other than that one detail
from no way home so i'm interested in
seeing what sort of powers and backstory
goal having this and i cannot stop stop
laughing at the last minute trailer so
i've never read any comic with gore in
it but i know the comic community has i
mean my favorite villains galactus and i
love dr doom
so what you know where they've all got
very different taste saudis so i don't
really know anything about gore so i
thought we would do what i always do
when i discover a villain i don't know a
ton about
i've only seen reference most of the
time is look them up on marvel uh fandom
this is goal
let's find out a little bit about him
okay it fell from this guy many years
ago a world without a name i picked it
up and butchered my first gods and then
as i stood there baptized in their blood
a question formed in my simple little
brain i wonder if there are more
aliases all black the necroverse black
butcher butcher of gods cloud stalker
god butcher
god of god butchers go the redeemer and
killer of gods
gore the butcher was born on a planet
with no name almost every day on the
brink of starvation
he was taught to trust in the gods but
they never answered his prayers at an
early age his mother and father died
leaving god to fend for himself in a
harsh environment years later he married
and fathered some children however most
of them died gore's pregnant mate ara
was killed during an earthquake and one
by one his children perished until he
was left with one son
agar
when agar was on the brink of death due
to starvation gore sought to ease his
suffering and told his son that they
would soon reach a forest where they
would never go hungry again
stricken with grief after agar's death
gore gave up hope and outwardly
expressed his belief that there were no
gods for which he was exiled by his
superstitious people
while wandering the desert praying to
die gore witnessed a pair of battling
gods a dark elder god called null and a
gold armored purple-skinned god
empowered by the enigma force plunge out
of the sky and crash land nearby shocked
by the realization that gods did exist
gore was enraged when the gold armored
god begged for help the dark gods sword
transforming into an amorphous mass of
living darkness and bonding to him
gore used his new weapon all black the
necro sword to kill the gold armored god
then vowed to seek vengeance against all
gods for never answering his prayers and
set out to kill them all gore despised
any god and traveled the cosmos for
thousands of years to exact as revenge
embarking on a decidal crusade in which
he allegedly killed many gods of fear
war chaos genocide revenge plagues
earthquakes blood wrath jealousy death
depredation and a few gods of poetry and
flowers
so i guess he's got some history with
thor i kind of don't want to read the
rest of this in case they pull from it
that may be all
following on it later but he has had
some battles
with thor
so ultimately won unsurprisingly
i wonder how long he's been around for
that would be why i was reading comics a
little bit before that um mostly in high
school was when i was very very into
comics
uh so he's a little bit newer which
makes sense i stopped um reading them
weekly in 2010
or marvel comics at least so that makes
sense anyway super interesting yeah
trailer looks really fun gonna be a lot
of fun agree the cinematography looks
really good
the trail is really good
yeah i'm in agreement
especially after like the awkward cg
of uh
she-hulk it's nice to just sort of
be back to you your regular
lovely high-budget cg
[Laughter]
let me know what you guys think